were in Dublin were in our nians pub
which is just down the road from Trinity
College which is Ireland's oldest
University very very many famous
physicists drank here in O'Neill's pub
including Ireland's most eminent
physicist Ernest Walton Ireland physics
it's sort of obvious that we're going to
think about Guinness so Guinness is a
beer as a stout very very much favored
in in in Ireland in here we've got
roasted barley we've got harps we've got
yeast we've got an awful lot of very
interesting physics going on but let's
start with the head first this very
famous head which looks white and creamy
first question is why is it white well
if you looked at this onto a microscope
what you'll actually see is that this is
a foam it's made up of thousands and
thousands and thousands of tiny little
bubbles unlike the vast majority of
other beers those bubbles actually have
nitrogen inside and this is what makes
that the head on a pint of Guinness
looked so sort of aesthetically pleasing
look some look so nice fluid is leaking
out gases exchanging if we could look at
that in real detail what we see is
smaller bubbles shrinking bigger bubbles
growing which see all this cautioning
processes happening it's although it
looks completely static at that level we
could zoom in there's a huge amount of
dynamics going on and that's fascinated
very very many physicist Lord Kelvin for
example he was from Belfast so depending
on your point of view another Irish
physicist was very very interested in
the physics of foam and Kelvin actually
thought the best description of the
ether at the time and sort of space-time
was that it was full like and in fact
there's a lot of fun a lot of
interesting debate as to the extent to
which space actually is foam like but
let's get back to the Guinness one thing
that is fascinated very many people is
well why is it got this particular color
why is it why is it white and obviously
that the the body of the beer the body
of the stout here is well most people
think it's black if you actually look at
it carefully it's all more sort of
moving red this arises from how light
scatters off these tiny tiny bubbles so
we're familiar with the sky obviously
PTIN blue and that's due to a process
called Rayleigh scattering where the
light hit strikes molecules in the
atmosphere
and we get preferred scattering of blue
light this is a process that's actually
called me scattering where the particles
in this case four bubbles are bigger and
in that case pretty well the light
there's no preferred wavelength but all
the light is scattered in its scattered
effectively equally well give or take a
few little niceties here and there one
thing that's also very many people have
thought about and wondered about and
puzzled about and was really only in
2004 that it was understood why this
happened is that there's always been
this large debate about do the bubbles
go up or do they go down in guinness and
many people have gone for one camp or
the other and like many of these things
it turns out that both are true but
you'd say well of course if you think of
just about the physics of course the
bubbles are going to go there's a
buoyancy there there's a buoyant force
that drives them up to the surface why
would they ever go down again it turns
out that you again it looks like so many
things that look so straightforward and
so mundane the physics is actually
really really complicated to the extent
where this is a paper a really really
good paper in a journal called the
physics of fluids which is an important
journal for those interested in fluid
processes so what they're doing is
they're trying to understand what the
hell is going on in Guinness and this is
2008 and I think it's fair to say that
although they've got there quite a lot
of the physics order there are very many
things that they'd still don't
understand so this is really hardcore
weather they've looked at this in
considerable detail spent a lot of time
thinking about this process and you may
think all it's just bloody physicists or
mathematicians counting engines on the
headed pens and you know why can't they
go and find something better to do than
throwing work out was going to Guinness
but the key thing is you understand
these processes are going on guinness
the waves that forming guinness the
where the bubbles move are so important
for so many industrial processes
something it's so important for you know
food industry and right across the board
the key piece of physics that's
happening here is that there's a
circulation there's a current going on
there's a flow of liquid going on in the
beer so what happens is that in the
centre if we could look right in the
center the bubbles there are moving up
but those those bubbles actually move up
and then when they get to the surface
they move towards the side they
entrained what's towards train they pull
liquid with them
and that pulling up the liquid sets up a
flow almost like infection but different
physics but almost like in vector you
get a flow and so it goes up in the
middle out and then goes down at the
sides and at the sides the drag on the
side of the glass leads to the bubbles
actually being pulled down so if you
look at this with a high-speed camera
it's like a very very tricky experiment
to do depending on where your depth of
focus and where you're looking at in the
in the glass bubbles either go up or
they go down why do they always use
Guinness and this for these experiments
with a recently used Guinness is that
those bubbles and the regional bubbles
are reformed this wonderful froth is
because on nitrogen are not carbon
dioxide or a mixture of nitrogen carbon
dioxide but the key ingredient here is
nitrogen and the diffusion of nitrogen
is very different from the diffusion of
carbon dioxide and all the dynamics
that's going on is influenced by the
diffusion in in Guinness the the
material in Guinness are actually goats
the bubbles and that coating that's a
fact and layer changes the dynamics of
how the bubble moves through that the
fluid and really influences its velocity
and surfactants are really really
important again in terms of detergents
but not just in detergents and in a wide
range of industrial processes a lot of
incredibly intriguing physics in every
time you go to the pub
one of the other really interesting
things about foam is that well what is
it is it a solid is it a liquid is it a
gas well first of all you might look at
you think well it's it's it's a liquid
and certainly air to flow like a liquid
but there are very few liquids you can
you can draw patterns in so that's been
very much like a solid and yet also if
you look at how its pressure changes and
its volume changes in it in terms of
refuge into temperature it behaves like
a gas so it's like this mixed air
between solid gas and liquid so which is
that a liquid a solid salt rate it's all
free and it's not the ring so yeah I was
never conscious of the way I pronounce
the word tree until I went to lecture
and Nottingham in the first set of
questionnaires I got back were riddled
with things like dirty tree and a turd
so so yes apologies and it's very very
how can I put it embarrassing to be
corrected on your pronunciation of the
word tree by your five-year-old daughter
obviously no daddy it's not tree it's
the ring so Kelvin was was fascinated by
foam and he tried to develop or did
develop a model for the the most
effective packing of dry bubbles
basically in a three dimensional form
now in a two dimensional form that's
actually a very common structure and
that's basically your honeycomb I can
see that the highest parking that the
most efficient use of space as well in
three dimensions it's unbelievably more
complicated and you have these
structures which I'm going to cheat now
because I always forget what this is
called identical 14 sided cells called
tetrakaidecahedron and now it was
thought for a hundred years that this
was the most efficient parking now it
turns out that a hundred years later in
Trinity College just down the road
we're who's a professor of physics there
and his student Phelan found that there
was a structure that was 0.3 percent
better than the Calvin model again you
might think well what are the argument
percent importantly it's telling you a
lot about the the the energy in this
system and how you can control and
constrain the energy the old ones here
and the new ones here and so there's a
difference here they're all identical
cells here there are two slightly
different types of cells which give you
a slightly better packing in the foyer
of one of the physics buildings in
Trinity College there's a model of this
which has also been used for one of the
buildings for the Beijing Olympics that
they exploited this type of structure
there's something called the equation of
state and many of you might have come
across this is where you've got pressure
volume and temperature pressure times
volume is equal to number of moles times
the gas constant times temperature and
with no I'm not going to go there stutes
now I'll end up buried in maths
from one aspect this is quite
intercourse you could argue that well
it's a bit stereotypical that they've
taken an Irish man from sixty symbols
and dumped them in a pub it's perhaps
less stereotypical is that I'm teetotal
so I don't drink I don't drink alcohol
so perhaps that's not quite so
stereotypical so I don't really drink
games go on
nice